At the beginning of each module all I
ask you to open up a playground file
like this one.
That file will contain the examples
I will walk through so
you can follow along.
A second file will contain exercises for
you to do on your own.
You can download all the files for the
course from the link in the instructors
notes at the beginning of each lesson.
Go ahead and download the playground
files for lesson one now.
Then open up the file entitled
Lesson One, Types and Operators.
If your playground doesn't
look like this, but
instead has a bunch of green comments.
You'll want to change one of
the settings up here in the editor menu.
Go down to here where where my
menu says show ROM mark up.
Yours might say show rendered markup.
So you want to click on it if
it says show rendered markup.
Then it should look like this.
I'm going to start by quickly
running through the definitions of
Swift's primitive types.
Swift's primitive types don't
have too many surprises.
Here in this light switch class
the on property is a bool.
Swift booleans always have
a value of true or false.
They can't be assigned to zero or one as
in C, or yes or no as in Objective C.
If you don't recognize any
of this syntax, don't worry.
That's to be expected.
I'll explain class and
property definitions soon,
along with this dot syntax.
For now just focus on the data types.
For properties that need
to hold continuous values,
we might want to use the int type,
which holds an integer.
For example if our light
switch had a dimmer.
I'll give our light
switch a dimmer property.
And then I'll set that dimmer
property to be of type int.
What if we wanted to
set our dimmer to pi.
If we want this dimmer property
to be able to represent decimals,
we can try using a float
instead of an int.
Of course if we use a double then we can
get a more precise representation of pi.
Here I've carried it
out to eleven digits.
Between float and double,
you can decide which type to use based
on the level of precision you need.
Strings and characters in Swift
are pretty much as you would expect.
Naturally the character type
holds a single character,
and the string type represents
an ordered collection of characters.
The Swift string type comes
with a handy bag of tricks,
that makes string manipulations nice and
concise.
Like this simple string concatenation.
Here in the playground sidebar you
can see the concatenated string.
We'll have more fun with strings and
the exercises at the end of the lesson.
There are two other Swift types
that require a deeper dive.
The first is the optional type,
which is the focus of the next lesson.
And the second is tuples, which we'll
talk about in the collections lesson.
For now, just know of their existence.
Before we finish,
there's a secret I haven't revealed.
See how I've indicated the type for
each of these variables?
I can actually take all of
these type indicators out.
But the compiler is having no
problem inferring the correct type.
And we can even test that by taking
a look at the type of these variables.
Let's try this concatenated string.
This dynamic type property can be
used to investigate any objects type.
And we can see over here in the sidebar
that the type of concatenated string
is a Swift string.
And the compiler was able to infer that,
even though we didn't indicate
it directly in the definition.
In the upcoming quiz,
you get to play the role of compiler and
do some type inference of your own.